when i look at your rise and look i talk
to people who
love what you do i mean every time i go
on the road and i'm speaking at a campus
you're the number one name that gets
mentioned at people by people who come
to my lectures and i think that the
reason for that that i've that i've seen
is is really twofold one is that
one of the things that you really talk a
lot about is the notion of
self-discipline and purpose in your life
and control and the idea that you are in
control of your decision making and your
decision making
matters that's one and the other is that
you have you have a
unique capacity to to say no to things
and when somebody says something to you
that is illogical but popular
that you have the capacity to say no
that's what happened in that kathy
newman interview that
somebody was saying something to you
that made no sense and you just said
well
no and then you just stood on that no
and when you stand on that no i think it
gives people a lot of courage
yeah well i mean the the gender issue is
really an interesting one because
one of my professional domains of
expertise is individual differences i'm
i'm a personality psychologist and so
i know the gender difference literature
and
it's it's a very solid literature well
first of all
it's very solid it has a 30-year history
once per psychologist got the
personality models down so that would be
the big five model
all empirically derived straight
statistics right brute force empiricism
nobody had a theoretical axe to grind
with the big five except to say
maybe there are human traits maybe
they're encapsulated in language
we can use statistical techniques to
find out what they are that was it
that's the whole
ideology so very very neutral as far as
ideologies go
five traits emerge okay
are there differences between the sexes
turns out there are
all right they're not massive although
if you sum them across all the traits
you can separate men and women with
about 75
accuracy so it's not trivial but you
have to sum across all the traits
then another question comes up well are
those differences
sociocultural or biological okay we can
test that
we'll go around the world we'll look at
cultures we'll rank order them in terms
of the
gender equality of their sociological
policies
we can do that with broad agreement from
the right and the left
then the hypothesis would be if gender
differences decrease
among more egalitarian societies then
the gender differences are sociocultural
or at least more sociocultural
that's exactly the opposite of what was
found
repeatedly that's pseudoscience it's
like no
that's mainstream psychology those
papers have thousands of citations and
right
the average humanities paper has zero
citations right and then the next most
common one has one
three thousand that's an that's an
unbelievable classic
and and here's the other bit of proof
like you say well how do you know
that you can trust someone's judgment
about a fact
the fact emerges despite their
ideological presuppositions
okay so it's well known that the social
sciences
and the humanities have a have a left
tilt and a lot of that's temperamental
and the tilt has become more pronounced
but as jonathan heidis pointed out
there are no conservatives among social
personality psychologists or
or none to speak very few vanishingly
few
and if the field has a bias it is
definitely and
indisputably a left-wing bias okay so
you have to fight that if you're
if you're a scientist right even if
you're a left-wing scientist you have to
fight that because you want to get to
the facts
it was these social scientists who
generated the data that suggested that
the gender differences not only were
real but that were bigger in egalitarian
societies
they didn't do that to grind their
ideological acts because their
ideological presupposition was
no no you make the society egalitarian
men and women get more the same it's
like
nope they get more different oh hmm
isn't that something and so then there's
a corollary there which is
all right you could still say and
they're kind of pushing in this
direction in scandinavia
boys and girls are different men and
women are different it looks biological
but because people are malleable you
could push the sociocultural structure
harder and harder to minimize the
biological differences
okay well first of all maybe and maybe
not maybe you'd get a rebound and they'd
get
even like the kids would rebel that
could easily happen
but let's say okay you could the problem
with that is is that
if you seed that much power to the state
like you're basically giving the state
the right to socialize your kids
right it's like you you really
really you really want to do that i mean
people in israel couldn't do that with
the cabooses that's right
it didn't work so people aren't going to
give up their children to the state and
thank god for that well i mean
this is one of the big questions that we
were discussing earlier is that we were
talking about
the polarization and politics between
right and left and obviously you're
you're a psychologist you're a
philosopher but
you've been dragged almost kicking and
screaming into this political sphere
because
everything has been so politicized and
so when you say when you cite social
science statistics and they're
scientifically based
you're called a racist you're called the
sexist you're called the homophobe
and you're called exactly so why is it
that
so why do you think it is that so many
folks on the left who purport to be all
about
reason and science and and objective
fact are so willing to
throw those out the window uh the minute
that it becomes politically inconvenient
well
because imagine that cognitive systems
or
an interpretation of the world has
levels they're axiomatic levels
some fundamental presuppositions are
more fundamental than others
and you could say well the leftists
historically maybe because of their
atheistic rationality
are more on the side of science than say
the fundamentalists
of any sort but when push comes to shove
you find out how the axioms are are
nested
there's deeper axioms underneath that
which is that
all hierarchies are based on power and
all
power plays are based on group identity
tribal identity essentially
and that the entire history of the world
is nothing but a power play between
between these different identity groups
it's like okay well if the science
indicates that some of that's wrong then
do you alter
those beliefs or do you alter the
science and the answer to that question
is well it depends on how you've
hierarchically arranged those
if the science is at the bottom then you
alter your beliefs
right if the scientific facts are the
axiomatic
substructure then you then you alter
your beliefs if your beliefs are the
axiomatic substructure then you alter
the science
well we've seen how that plays out and
one of the things i've tried to do so to
speak is to diagnose the axiomatic
structure
it's like okay what's the what's the
metaphysical
presumption structure of the radical
left well
what it is is you're basically your
group
your groups are basically engaged in
warfare
right and the warfare is arbitrary
except insofar as it serves
your group okay i don't buy any of that
i think that's
i think that's a root to certain
disaster i think it's a degeneration
into tribalism
and that we will seriously pay for it
not only because it returns us to
tribalism and tribes fight as
the anthropological evidence for that is
overwhelming right
tribes fight it doesn't even matter if
they're chimpanzee tribes
even chimpanzee tribes fight so
not only do you re regress to a
tribalism
but you also invalidate the one
proposition that's
been able to help us arise above the
tribal which is the idea that the
individual should be sovereign
and so i think the culture war is about
what's the proper framework within which
to view
human identity and what's the
relationship between the individual and
the group
in relationship to that identity and the
leftist answer is
it's all group and it's all power it's
like okay
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button and
stay up to date on all of our content